in my years fighting crime I've learned
one truth that every villain is the hero
of his own story
you better than this larger that's the
problem fighting for truth and justice
the battle never end when does it stop
when there's no more crime
we're forward
I won't hurt you unless that happens
hope isn't enough to save the world none
of us want to see
can either with me or against me
we both knew it'd come to this was only
a matter of time i'll try to make it
painless
hey everybody It's Charlie! we got all kinds of
crazy injustice cutscene to break down
let's do it a lot of you also requested
that I talked about that supposed arkham
game leak so i added that to the end of
the video but this is so cool
so this is picking up right after the
last game left off in the explain that
because they didn't want to repeat the
batman be superman things from the first
game that they brought in Brainiac is
the new villain with the society being
like the new regime type organization
that Batman has to rise up and fight
because a lot of his old alliances like
this they shattered alliances in the
trailer of either become collaborators
are victims of the regime so basically
like all the teams are getting shattered
everybody's getting mixed up and then
Brainiac is coming in with this new
society group so if you're new to the
channel you have no idea what's going on
i do DC videos every week for the game
stuff too, be sure to subscribe to get
everything because there's a whole bunch
of injustice coming i'm doing a giveaway
that i'll explain at the end of the
video too the other big twist the
darkside teaser at the end is something
else too
he's seeing all this chaos and taking
advantage of it so he just like one of
the playable bonuses
there's also a couple other characters
that you don't seem that the premium
skin like Jon Stewart Power Girl
reverse-flash and this is kind of crazy
but it seems like a no-brainer because
it's nether realm boo basically says
they're putting scorpion in as DLC so
you can actually play with the Mortal
Kombat character in the injustice game
but if you don't remember the story from
the end of the first injustice game what
happened is is that the good superman
from the alternate universe came in and
helped defeat regime Superman this evil
version of superman this is like the
full big cut scene from the end of that
game so enjoy your reign is over
you won't terrorized these people any
longer
here is the only thing these people
understand one day you'll learn
you'll have to kill me no not even you
there's been enough
Superman accomplices have been rounded
up or turn themselves in the next job is
restoring civil order the transitional
government has a tangible we're here if
they need help
thanks but no the people need to know
they're in control not us
so you haven't changed your mind I
respect the president's offer but I
don't belong in government
none of us do you think that man is a
future here crime and corruption will
return Hollywood have called me a
pessimist i'm just being realistic and
you're Superman he'll stand trial they
all will he was right now about what put
in the same position i might have done
the same thing we never know what we're
truly capable off i hope for your world
sick you never find out
just keep ya if something ever happens
when you do lose it i'm coming for you
we'll have to get online
so they put him in prison and this is
basically where you pick up at the
beginning of this trailer here where
he's getting out of prison so it's like
okay I map my regime has freed me and
now it almost looks like the Damian
Wayne Robin is going to be going up
against his version of Batman they're
not getting too complicated with
alternate universe characters here so
it's basically everybody's friends
turning on each other in a way that you
didn't see in the first game because you
don't like it we thought that means by
Superman we don't want to repeat that
outright it has to be something that's
much more compelling and what's more
compelling than damian wayne deciding
that his father is not extreme enough
that's why i love his character so much
but this is obviously like a much older
version of the character than you see in
the animated movies in the cartoons they
actually just started that super sons
comic if you're real big fan of the idea
of young damian wayne teaming up with
the son of pre-crisis Superman John Kent
so the other thing about this that I'm
wondering is that they're going to have
dlc for Damian Wayne to get his Batman
costume because there's a number of
versions of the continuity there's
always like an alternate future version
where you get to see Damien who has
picked up the mantle of the bat after
his father Bruce Wayne has died
now usually he just like a more hardcore
sword-wielding Batman but his costume
looks pretty badass and I know a lot of
people because of the Nightwing news in
the dce you the actual DC movies are
wondering if maybe you know Ben Affleck
wants to leave in a couple years if
they'll just transition Grayson into the
role of Batman this big thing about
people taking the Cal I don't know if
they'll ever get to battle for the
calendar movies but the thing about the
game that so-called is easy just give
the character that skin so you can kind
of do a version of that story life
without having to wait six years to get
to it
the other big thing a lot of you are
asking about is that new arkham game
that supposed to be announced in march
there was like a save-the-date teaser
everyone's like something really big is
coming from the Arkham people and then
supposedly somebody claiming to be from
the WB Montreal studio who is leaving
his job and it's like I don't care
anymore is like the redhead line so you
take it with a grain of salt said that
it's going to be an insurgency game or
like Arkham revolution where the
underworld resist
Batman's rule in orchestrates a mass
breakout so that might be the basis for
the story of the next arkham game but
they're going to be announcing next
month anyway so we won't have to wait
that long to find out but here's like
the big bullet points from his big info
dump so to take it with a grain of salt
but he says it's been in development
since 2014 takes place three years after
the event of batman arkham origins
playable characters will include Batman
and Robin with a dick grayson Robin not
Nightwing i know a lot of people were
like maybe damian wayne is going to be
Batman in this that was supposedly going
to be a thing but apparently that's not
the case 3 it will introduce a new
location in Gotham a coastal area that
he claims is supposed to be the same
size as three islands from Arkham Knight
just like a really big story area for
the game players are supposed to be able
to fast travel between the Batcave and
Wayne Manor the mechanics of the
Batmobile have been completely changed
there's no more battle mode when you're
chasing people combat features are a
little more dynamic that's a no-brainer
the big villain include Maximillian Zeus
dollmaker Killer Moth Anarchy two-phase
blockbuster ventriloquist Cornelius
sturt Tweedledee and Tweedledum to Sanaa
ghoul mad monk dollar Riddler and Joker
and then this last really big one is
kind of weird it's a bit of a
head-scratcher so he says that foul man
is the main don't know the game but then
he also named him alongside the court
about in the talents who are going to be
like this big elite bosses but the
problem is is that a Taliban it just
earth three Batman so I don't know if
he's talking about talent from DC comics
and mistakenly said element or if it's
genuinely aliment from another universe
has come to our earth so if this is true
at all i think that it's the Thomas
Wayne talent it's not aliment because
you have like all these normal villains
in the single continuity why would you
include somebody from an alternate
universe he doesn't totally makes sense
so the first is leaking this is actually
being truthful
maybe he's not like a big comic book
person he's just a big games person
either way new arcade game you in just
this game they're both going to be
awesome i'll be giving away copies as we
go forward and doing gameplay videos on
my game channel Charlie strangers
Lincoln that
description for that but i only post a
couple videos a week to that channel but
there is new
deadpool 2 that is coming up and i'll
be posting later tonight on the main
channel as well as a whole bunch of
x-men universe they explain the future
of the x-men universe and then there's
some brand-new DCTV too because they're
talking about next year's for night
crossover but the DC TV stuff might not
post so monday because i got game of
thrones tomorrow with walking dead so
it's kind of booked for sunday but
there's a new round of the injustice 2
give away all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Willie Rodriguez please private
message me on the back into my channel
so i can get your contact details
what's going to happen next is a post
that Deadpool to that should be up in a
couple hours while you wait for that you
can click here to learn all about that
NIghtwing movie that's coming up and you
can click here for all about Iron Fist
defenders thank you so much for watching
let's high five, i'll see you guys in the
next video!